have you ever thought about stopping and
said to yourself you know
there's easier ways to spend my life all
the time
i mean i've you know carved out a career
for myself as a marketing and creative
professional
you know copywriting and art directing
and things like that and
if i really gave myself to that maybe i
could be very successful but i feel like
there would
i there would be this hole inside of me
that would just be
devoid um you know i think that maybe
maybe i'm not very smart maybe i should
have given up a long time ago because i
keep you know
putting myself through this and you know
trying and keep going
but i think that that's part of the
challenge that a lot of writers face is
the self-doubt
and the imposter syndrome and especially
as a woman and trying to break through
in this industry it's very hard um yeah
you grapple with that all the time and
writing by nature is a very solitary
activity
um it's it's very easy to
want to throw in the towel and that's
why it's so important to celebrate those
little victories just
one little thing you know one one
connection one
one interview one you know chance
encounter
uh could change your world
but by naming the imposter syndrome and
sort of calling it out does that
take away its power a little bit you
have to be aware of it when it's
happening i mean there are there are
times
you know and i think that this comes
with age and maturity as well i mean
certainly i'm
i'm more grounded now that i am in my
30s than i was in my 20s
um i'm able to own my mistakes more
readily i'm able to
objectively look at myself and
you know separate
the the need of me that need or the part
of me that needs approval
um to the part of me that that you know
is trying to
to create something as well so that if i
can give myself enough space
to fail then i can i can help overcome
that imposter syndra but it's
it's not an easy thing to do and i know
a lot of people grapple with it
but when you're in that space of writing
about just some character that is
our it's so real it's speaking to you
it's kind of scary it might be a little
edgy
is that sounds like it's not being an
imposter by any means
that's such a rare state of
enlightenment that you know it's like i
said it's like
it's almost like getting a runner's high
it's not it doesn't happen all the time
but it is magic when it does
you